some people said well I thought you were  all about Freedom you know what is this  about banning companies and all this  other stuff I thought capitalists and  Republicans and all this stuff were all  about freedom and Libertarians are all  about Freedom yeah except if the enemy  is using a technology to divide and  dummify your people that is the enemy  you are naive if you think and so all  these Patriot Act that we have that are  spying on America fine I'm more  comfortable having my own country spy on  us than I have with a China our number  one enemy spying on us I don't want  anybody spying on anybody period but  it's definitely not going to be the  Enemy of the State number one which is  China